for more information on tutoring or how
to support move university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university comm thank you and enjoy
so in this video we're going to discuss
the Bohr model and its limitations in
1913 Niels Bohr proposed a model for the
hydrogen atom which is actually a pretty
important part of this that explained
the existence of line spectra which we
begin to talk about we got to talk about
in the previous video so this is his
model here basically keep in mind that
it was for the hydrogen atom that's
actually really important part of this
it's for the hydrogen atom which is just
it's just one one proton and one
electron okay so this is his model so we
got the nucleus here with one proton
represented by this plus sign and then
we have the electron here II - okay and
basically what he said is that we've got
the nucleus here in the center and the
electron can be of course outside the
nucleus and it travels in specific paths
right in specific sort of circular paths
around the nucleus and there are a bunch
of different paths and each of these
paths these circular paths you see here
some are closer to the nucleus and some
are further away but these little rings
around it and each of these paths is
called an orbit okay and each of these
orbits was at a distinct energy level
which means that the energy of the
energy here was quantized okay so if an
electron is in a certain orbit for
instance if it's in the N equals one
orbit anywhere in that orbit if it's
here or if it's over here or if it's
over here does not matter doesn't matter
where it is as long as it's in that
orbit it's the energy of it is the same
anywhere in that orbit
okay now I'm something else that's
important is that this electron can be
of course closer to the nucleus or
further away right the closer it is the
nucleus the lower end energy it is and
the further away it is the higher energy
it is okay so each of these orbits sort
of is denoted as n equals one and equals
two N equals 3 you know and further and
so on and so forth it doesn't stop at 6
I just stop at 6 because I only have so
much room okay so the idea was though
that as the N value increases energy
increases now why might that be
well think about this the electron is
negatively charged the proton is
positively charged they want to be close
to each other right so if you try just
imagine trying to pull this electron
away that's going to require energy
right this if once this electron is
further away that's not a situation it
really wants to be in it wants to get
back so that that that to get it away
would have to would require energy and
it's going to be higher in energy if
it's further away from where it wants to
be okay so that that hopefully makes
sense right because the electrons are
attracted to the positively charged the
positive charged positively charged the
positive charge of the nucleus so they
want to be closer not further in fact if
it's at the electron is at the N equals
one orbit then it's considered to be at
the ground state right and if it's at an
N value higher than one it's considered
to be in the excited state okay now what
happens here is that lets say this
electron let's say we have this electron
here actually let's say we have an
electron in the N equals three orbit
okay I brought us in a different color
let's do let's do purple so let's say
like I said we have one in the N equals
three orbit and it wants to go I know it
doesn't want to go let's say we try to
take it to
to the N equals five orbit okay that is
going to require energy right this
requires energy
okay so energy this electron has to
absorb energy so energy is absorbed here
because because it requires energy to
get from a lower energy level to a
higher energy level okay energy is
absorbed okay
how much energy it's the amount of
energy that is equal to the difference
of energy at the N equals three level
and the N equals five level so it's a
specific amount right the energy
absorbed equal to the difference
in energy between the two levels that's
specifically how much energy will be
absorbed okay
the flipside if we have an electron
maybe out here in the end equals six and
wants to come down to the N equals two
in order to get that to happen the
opposite occurs energy is emitted
energy is released right because this is
happening this electron wants this to
happen does require energy energy is
released here energies emitted again how
much specifically it's equal to the
difference in energy between the two
energy levels now we mentioned in the
previous video the different series
right the UV series visible C reason and
the V IR series and we said that when M
equals 1 or Sumeet when N equals 1 we're
talking about the UV series so that is
here okay - the UV series so we're
talking about electrons going from outer
outer shells or outer energy levels or
outer orbits down to the N equals 1
orbit that corresponds to the spectral
lines in the UV portion if we're talking
about them coming down to the N equals 2
orbit that's the visible series talking
about the N equals 3 coming down to the
N equals 3 that's the IR series okay so
boarded a really good job explaining
this this model for the hydrogen atom
and it explained the existence of the
line spectra that we mentioned in the
previous video so what was its
limitation the issue was that the only
atom let's write this in white here the
only atom that the Bohr model worked for
or or works for is the hydrogen atom now
it works for other 1 electron species
like the ions h e+ or lithium 2-plus
or beryllium 3 plus all of these species
have only one electron right helium has
an atomic number of two and if it loses
which means it has two electrons right
if it loses one of those electrons it
only has one electron so this model
works for anything that only has one
electron for other atoms though it does
not apply this does not fit
and the reason why is that electrons do
not follow fixed orbits okay the only
atom that this works for is the hydrogen
atom so you might be thinking okay so
why is this important who cares if this
thing is wrong then why do we even think
about it at all
well one important thing to take home
from from what's going on at the Bohr
model is that that an atoms energy
occurs as specific or discrete levels
that much is definitely true
now the exact situation of what's going
on is modeled here in the in the
hydrogen atom well but for other atoms
this is not exactly the case but this
this this like I said this this this key
point here is true for other atoms not
just for the hydrogen atom so I hope
that video was helpful in kind of going
over the Bohr model and why it's it's
not the the best model for for atoms so
later we'll see kind of what is kind of
going on with the electrons that are
flowing around the nucleus in other
atoms hope that video is helpful thank
you for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying